es ist mal wieder Zeit mit dem Jahr
abzurechnen wir schon jetzt zurück und
guck mal wie ich mich so als
Selbstversorger hin geschlagen habe
kurze Zusammenfassung was ich hier
überhaupt mache mein Ziel ist es
eigentlich das Obst und Gemüse für meine
Familie fast komplett selber anzubauen
von Ernteausfällen und der ein oder
anderen Banane die wir einfach nicht
selber anbauen können die mein Sohn aber
sehr gerne essen möchte mal abgesehen
aber alles was wir hier anbauen können
das wollen wir eigentlich auch selber
anbauen und dann haben wir noch Hühner
von denen wir die Eier bekommen und ich
habe Ziegen für Milch und Fleisch können
wir den Ziegen nicht alle Milchprodukte
selber herstellen z.b. machen wir keinen
Hartkäse und wir können auch keine
Butter herstellen aber eigentlich ist
mein Ziel so viel eigene Milchprodukte
wie möglich zu produzieren dieses Jahr
war bei der persönlichen Ebene für mich
super hart haben sie sehr sehr viele
Sachen für mich geändert darüber möchte
ich jetzt auch gar nicht reden weil das
ist nicht das Thema um dass es hier auf
meinem Kanal geht das hat sich aber auch
auf unsere Selbstversorgung ausgewirkt
auf jeden Fall hat sich das ausgewirkt
ja manchmal ärgert mich das ein bisschen
ich war dieses Jahr sehr sehr sehr viel
und bewegst und sehr wenig zu Hause und
habe dadurch teilweise Sachen nicht
mitbekommen im Garten war zu den
wichtigen Zeitpunkten einfach nicht da
habe nicht mitbekommen dass Schädlinge
oder Krankheiten sich ausbreiten weil
wenn du es erst drei Wochen später
siehst dann ist es halt meistens einfach
schon zu spät das hat es mir sehr sehr
schwer gemacht
mich selbst zu versorgen weil ich
einfach kein Wort hatte an dem ich lange
Zeit war ich rede auf meinem Kanal auf
nicht so viel über die Ziegen die sind
aber für mich ein richtig wichtiger Teil
der Selbstversorgung ich habe nur das
Gefühl dass Dir mein Ziegenhaltung geht
vielen Leuten den Schritt zu weit also
viele wollen einfach nicht so krass viel
Selbstversorgung betreiben und haben
auch einfach den Platz nicht und
deswegen spreche ich so wenig über die
Ziegen weil ich das Gefühl hab das
interessiert eigentlich so richtig
es ist aber so dass ein Garten Kalorien
mäßig einfach nicht wirklich viel ab
wäre also die meisten Kalorien die wir
zu uns nehmen die kaufen wir ganz normal
im Laden zu weil wir jetzt möchte kein
Getreide an abgesehen von meist kein
Getreide anbauen da wir kein Öl selber
herstellen wir können auch keine Butter
machen das kann man viel besser als aus
Kuhmilch als aus Ziegenmilch machen und
diese ganzen Sachen die wirklich satt
machen und wirklich Substanz haben von
dem man sich wirklich ernähren kann die
kaufen wir ja genauso weiter zu wie
jeder andere auch außer dass wir darauf
achten dass sie regional hergestellt
werden und im biologisch sind und so
weiter also dass sie mir schon sehr
wichtig da auf regionaler Ebene
Selbstversorgung zu betreiben und
regionale Hilfe zu unterstützen das
einzige was in unserer Selbstversorgung
so richtig Nährwert und Kalorien und so
eine andere Qualität von Lebensmittel
ranschafft sind die Ziegen mit ihrem
Fleisch und mit der Milch das ist
einfach was was der Garten Sony liefern
könnte und dieses Jahr hatten wir sehr
große Schwierigkeiten bei den Ziegen
also ich hatte auch nur eine Milchziege
weil es das normalerweise von der
Milchmenge sehr gut ausgereicht hat nur
eine Ziege zu melken die ist aber
letztes Jahr im Winter gestorben darüber
habe ich auch ein hier gemacht und das
war sehr sehr traurig auf der einen
Seite weil das einen Familienmitglied
war gefühlt also das war gerade die
Tiere die man melkt zu den hat man so
ein intimes Verhältnis weil du jeden Tag
dahin gehst und so eine ja wirklich
tiefe Bindung zu den Tieren aufbaust das
Melken ist eine unglaublich intensive
Zeit dass die Ziege gestorben ist war
schlimm und das Resultat war dann
natürlich dass wir gar keine Milch
hatten das ganze Jahr über auch keine
Zicklein dadurch kein Fleisch da hätte
ich noch irgendwo eine Milchziege kaufen
können und die dann melden aber ehrlich
gesagt habe ich das so ein bisschen satt
und ich habe auch eine sehr gute
Nachwuchs Milchziege mit der ich schon
sehr viel über die jetzt auch trächtig
ist und nächstes Frühjahr dann nehme ich
ihn bekommt und ich wollte ehrlich
gesagt nicht noch eine neue Ziege haben
dich dann ein melden muss jetzt denke
ich wieder drüber nach mir doch eine zu
holen weil ich denke jetzt hängt wieder
alles an dieser einzige was wenn ihr was
passiert das wäre natürlich schrecklich
aber ausschließen kann man das und dann
haben wir wieder keine Milch natürlich
ist dann wieder auch sehr traurig ich
will das jetzt gar nicht irgendwie
annehmen dass irgendwas passiert
normalerweise ist ja immer alles gut
aber so bisschen meine Lehre daraus dass
ich eigentlich gerne zwei Milchziegen
haben würde einfach um die Sicherheit zu
haben und auch weil man klar dann auch
mehr Milch hat das ist eigentlich gar
nicht schlecht aber gar nicht so viel
mehr Aufwand bei den ganzen Abwasch mit
den ganzen make Utensilien und die Milch
Verarbeitung muss man ja sowieso machen
ob man dann fünf Minuten länger meldet
oder zehn Minuten länger melkt und
doppelt so viel Milch verarbeitet ist
dann gar nicht mehr so der Unterschied
deswegen überlege ich gerade doch wir
noch eine Milchziege zuzulegen bin aber
auch schon sehr gespannt wie das mit
meiner kleinen Feder wird die habe ich
noch nie gemolken aber ich habe das
Gefühl dass dass das wegen gutes Team
sind ja eine Sache hat mir aber auch
noch viel mehr eine Strich durch die
Rechnung gemacht dieses Jahr aber ja
dazu erzähle ich gleich noch mehr jetzt
kommt noch eine kleine Erinnerung wenn
ihr meinen Aussaatkalender noch nicht
runtergeladen habe der ist jetzt fertig
also
wie ein Schmuckstück geworden fox noch
mal einen Kilian aus meinem Team der den
designt hat und auch Anke die da auch
viel dran gearbeitet hat super toll
geworden da findet ihr alle außer
Termine für alle möglichen Gemüse die
ihr in diesem Jahr anbauen wollte dass
ihr die gestaffelt aussetze dass ihr
rund ums Jahr ernten könnt also den Link
darf wir bei euch hier oben rein und
unten in die Videobeschreibung dass es
kostenloser Download könnt ihr
ausdrucken an die Wand hängen echt ein
richtig cooles Teil geworden also wenn
ihr die noch nicht habt ja ich habe es
schon mal angesprochen ich war es auch
gar nicht so arg thematisieren aber ich
habe mich einfach in den letzten Jahren
gnadenlos überarbeitet ich habe auch ein
paar Videos mal erwähnt dass ich so
60-70 Stunden Wochen habe und da kam
auch viele besorgte Kommentare und auch
Ungläubige Kommentare ich glaube
diejenigen von euch die selbständig sind
und wirklich für ihre Arbeit brennen die
können das wahrscheinlich nachvollziehen
dass es nicht übertrieben ist dass man
dann so viel auch arbeiten kann
das auch mehrere Jahre durchhalten kann
gerade weil ich den besten Job der Welt
habe ich meine ich kann den ganzen Tag
über gemüse reden ich habe so eine tolle
Community mit euch und es ist einfach
unglaublich cool und deswegen hänge ich
mich halt voll rein und das ist werde
ich auch nicht aufhören ich muss nur
einfach ein bisschen auf mich achten
dass ich ja das ist nicht so viel Byte
also ich glaube 40 Stunden pro Woche ist
ein gutes Maß und er versuche ich mich
jetzt auch dran zu halten ich muss mich
da auch sehr oft selber disziplinieren
aber es ergibt gar keinen Sinn den
ganzen Tag übers Gärtnern zu reden wenn
man dann selber keine Zeiten hat
rauszugehen und mit den Händen in der
Erde zu wühlen mein Garten hat auf jeden
Fall sehr unter meiner Arbeit gelitten
weil ich einfach von morgens bis abends
im Büro bin und viele denken im Wald
meine Arbeit bei Wurzelwerk würde darin
bestehen im Garten zu arbeiten aber das
ist leider nicht also außer ich Filme
was im Garten herum genau ist das meist
halt am Computer und hiermit
Videoschnitt zu tun mit you Reviews von
Videoschnitt und in welchem Clan wir
haben so viele Pläne und es ist ja nicht
nur dieser Youtuber keine heile das ist
ja nur ein kleiner Teil von Wurzelwerk
wird sie weg ist noch viel mehr z.b.
unser Blog erreicht noch viel mehr Leute
als dieser YouTube Kanal hier aus der
Tasche hast also wenn ihr irgendwelche
Probleme im Garten habt wo ihr hier
vielleicht keine Antwort darauf findet
dann schaut auf jeden Fall gerne mal auf
meinem Blog vorbei da gibt es auch eine
Suchleiste und da findet man sehr viele
Artikel zu allen möglichen Garten
Selbstversorger Team ja und das ist
einfach auf meiner Familie gegenüber
überhaupt nicht fair gewesen so viel zu
arbeiten und so wenig zu Hause zu sein
ich mag gerne Zeit mit meinem Sohn
verbringen weil es der wichtigste Mensch
den es überhaupt immer im Leben gibt und
mag auch irgendwie kein schlechtes
Gewissen haben wenn die Ziegen mal
wieder so süß sind dass ich nicht von
ihm wegkomme und noch ein paar Minuten
kuscheln will und das wird hoffentlich
auch dazu führen dass ich nächstes Jahr
wie vielmehr selbst dass er technisch
unterwegs sein kann was ich aber in
dieser ganzen Zeit vor allem gemerkt
habe ist was für ein kraftpol der Garten
und die Tiere und generell die Natur für
mich ist und dass ich das so arg brauche
gerade wenn es so turbulent ist und
außerhalb der der Selbstversorger Lebens
eben auch viel anderes Leben passiert
dann brauche ich das dass ich dann
irgendwie mal drei Stunden einfach nur
im Garten sitze und den Garten genieße
das ist einfach so wichtig und das erdet
mich so ungemein und davon will ich viel
mehr in meinem Leben haben und es hat
mir auch gezeigt wie wichtig es mir ist
Selbstversorgung zu betreiben ja ich
kann es gar nicht richtig in Worte
fassen aber ich glaube er kann es
nachempfinden und was ich so mit am
meisten gemerkt habe in den letzten
Monaten ist das Selbstversorgung
eigentlich alles sein kann und nicht
sein muss und das ist nicht darum geht
irgendwelche Quoten zu erfüllen es ist
doch absurd also Selbstversorgung muss
vor allem Spaß machen dass es auch der
Grund warum ich das mache und weil ich
jetzt Liebe richtig gutes Essen auf dem
Tisch zu haben und das hatten wir zwar
nicht immer aber sehr sehr viel und
dafür wie wenig Zeit ich eigentlich hier
war es ist ziemlich erstaunlich was der
Garten alles abgeworfen hat das liegt
auch zum Teil daran dass wir eben sehr
sehr Arbeit sparend Gärtnern also wir
haben Systeme im Garten z.b. die Kompost
Beete und der Mulde ich auch noch andere
Techniken die ich mir immer für meine
Kurse aus spare weil ich ja nicht alles
hier auf YouTube raushauen möchte was
was er nicht mehr in den Kulissen
vorkommt also es gibt sehr viele
Möglichkeiten um den Garten sehr Arbeit
sparend einzurichten und deswegen war es
auch kein Problem mal 2-3 Wochen am
Stück weg zu sein wenn man vorher alles
abgeerntet dann kommt der Garten auch so
ganz gut ohne einen aus ist einzige
Problem sind halt die die Krankheiten
und Schädlinge die man da nicht
mitkriegt und dass man in der Zeit dann
halt auch nicht Garten ist
aber was gießen oder jeden angeht hatten
wir da gar keine Probleme und das ist
auf jeden Fall sehr sehr schön zu sehen
dass sich die Selbstversorgung auch so
gut an die eigenen Bedürfnisse und und
meinen ganzen Veränderungen anpassen
konnte ich hatte auch eine sehr liebe
Ziegen Vertretung die anke hat sich
immer ganz gut um medizin gekümmert wenn
ich wegfahre auch Zuma und das ist ja
danke noch mal an euch mal das ist auf
jeden Fall sehr sehr schön wenn man weiß
es läuft auch ohne ein sehr gut weiter
und da war ich auf jeden Fall sehr
positiv überrascht das hatte ich nicht
erwartet das ist so so gut dann
letztendlich trotzdem gelaufen das was
ich daraus mitnehme und was ich auch
hoffe was ich euch mitgeben kann es
dieses Gefühl von
mach dir die Selbstversorgung so wie es
dir passt das soll Spaß machen das soll
Freude machen es ist total schön
rauszugehen und mit den Händen in der
Erde zu fühlen aber man muss da keine
Quoten erfüllen musst ja nicht sich
selbst irgendwas beweisen es geht ja
jetzt ja auch nicht darum dass man
irgendwie aus dem Garten überleben
können muss also das zumindest nicht
meine Anspruch und mir nimmt das sehr
viel Last von den Schultern zu sagen ich
mache so viel wie ich Lust drauf habe
und wie mir Spaß macht und wenn das
Leben dazwischen kommt und andere Sachen
einfach gerade wichtiger sind dann ist
das völlig in Ordnung wenn die
Selbstversorgung mal kurz hinten ansteht
und ich hoffe dass ihr auch euren Weg
findet der genau zu euch und eurem Leben
passend euren Umständen und euch da
keinen Druck macht euch nicht als
Versager fühlt weil ihr in diesem Jahr
vielleicht weniger geschafft hat als ihr
euch vorgenommen habt und trotzdem große
Ziele habt und und ganz viel Lust im
Herzen rauszugehen und ganz viel
umzusetzen ich habe die auf jeden Fall
ich freue mich auf jeden Fall total auf
das neue Jahr und hoffe dass alles ein
bisschen geordneter zugeht ich habe auf
jeden Fall große Ambitionen ich möchte
viel mehr Zeit draußen verbringen und
freue mich hoffentlich sehr darauf dass
das dann auch klappt ich habe vor kurzem
mit einer neuen Art von Videos an Angina
nicht sauer ist das sollen wohl für
Videos sein oh mann inspiriert wird
rauszugehen und loszulegen und wenn ihr
das noch nicht gesehen habt dann schaut
gerne mal da drüben vorbei ansonsten
geht raus und mach die Welt ein bisschen
grüne und wir sehen uns ab jetzt wieder
wöchentlich nächsten Samstag um 10 Uhr
für ein neues video tschüss ich freue
mich auf euch
[Musik]